we're gonna get an early look at this
week's 48 hours for you in 2016
lawrence rudolph and his wife bianca
went on a safari in zambia sounds good
but just before they returned home
bianca died from a shotgun wound not
good 48 hours contributor deborah patta
shows us how her very mysterious death
led to allegations of infidelity fraud
and murder
lawrence rudolph and his wife bianca
were on an exciting vacation in africa
until tragedy struck it was the end of
the rudolf zambian hunting trip they
were supposedly packing up and getting
ready to fly home
but then bianca rudolph suffered a fatal
gunshot wound lauren said he was in the
bathroom heard the shot and found his
wife bleeding dead on the floor he said
while bianca was packing the shotgun it
must have accidentally fired once the
hunting trip was ended the weapon should
have been rendered safe lawrence's
description raises questions says
retired fbi special agent and cbs news
consultant james galliano it boggles the
mind that two experienced hunters for
this to have been an accident game scout
spencer cacoma says he also has
questions he insists after the hunt the
guns were emptied of ammunition and you
saw bianca rudolph
cleaning her gun of life i mean you're
after two days of investigating police
in zambia closed the case finding the
shotgun accidentally fired meanwhile a
friend of bianca's grew concerned when
she learned lawrence had bianca's body
cremated within three days of her dying
the friend then contacted the fbi the
friends suggest a number of troubling
things miss rudolph was a devout
catholic and it expressed to her
explicitly that she would never consider
being cremated the fbi's investigation
would reveal among other details that
lawrence rudolph was involved in an
extramarital affair it all led to his
december 2021 arrest for the murder of
bianca lawrence rudolph's attorneys
indicate bianca had a will saying she
wanted to be cremated they say their
client is innocent writing in a
statement to 48 hours the feds brought
charges without any real evidence no
eyewitnesses no forensics no anything
no anything deborah potter joins us now
from johannesburg deborah always good to
see you but listen it's hard to imagine
a shotgun firing accidentally what else
did the fbi investigation reveal
good question indeed gail well according
to the fbi there were a number of other
troubling things there was nearly five
million dollars in life insurance
payouts also there are questions about
how bianca would have been able to shoot
herself even accidentally that it might
have simply been physically impossible
for a woman her size to point the gun at
herself and receive the kind of wounds
that she did gail
yeah you're right five million dollars
in insurance and reports of an
extramarital affair the optics don't
look so good thank you thank you very
much deborah pat in johannesburg